a few days ago Amazon announced the
director of the upcoming Lord of the
Rings serious plan Antonio Bayona will
take over from the cult director Peter
Jackson first of all he is only
responsible for the first two episodes
if they announced in a press release
Bayona is a lifelong fan of the series
and can hardly wait to take audiences
all over the world to middle-earth and
even though he's only responsible for
the first two episodes he's one of the
most important contributors to the
series being the first director to be in
charge of the look and other key details
Bayona has been known to the film road
at the latest since 2007 with his
production of the orphanage his most
successful engagement is probably his
role as director of Jurassic Road to
fallen Kingdom we are very curious to
see how Bayona will cope with the
certainly not easy task as Lord of the
Rings director and look forward to
further announcements on the Amazon
series since the beginning of the year
it is confirmed that there will be a
Netflix excusive Breaking Bad film with
director and creator Vince Gilligan
according to some fans Aaron Paul now
seems to have spread a rumor as he posts
a snapshot of himself and Brent Cranston
on Twitter with the caption even sooner
however this looks more like a souvenir
photo from a vacation than after the
announcement of a shooting start anytime
soon many fans clearly see the last one
in it and again who plays Walter White's
wife Skyler in the series gives the
all-clear in an interview with the One
Show according to their information it's
only an advertisement for a tequila that
will be released soon however it's also
questionable whether she if she knew
something would also reveal it since
when she was asked if she will be part
of the new film she answered that it was
a secret so you can speculate what the
picture is all about but you shouldn't
get your hopes up too high until we get
some official news soon fans have been
eagerly awaiting the flash solo movie
ever since the flash first appeared on
the DC extended universe a few months
ago the completion of the movie was even
not certain but now the shooting doesn't
seem to be too far away anymore and
maybe with a big surprise behind the
camera it and mama director
anti-mosquito is supposed to take over
the direction so if the Hollywood
Reporter's news is right and they hire
muschietti the question naturally arises
rather most gettable enter new film
territory or rather the flesh will
actually go in the horror direction ask
the main actor Ezra Miller wishes
additionally Christina Hudson a new
screenwriter has been brought on board
Hudson was most recently involved in the
transformer spin-off bumblebee and is
significantly involved in the production
of birds of prey so we will see what
happens with the flesh since the fixed
cinema release is not yet in sight but
if the shooting starts in the beginning
of next year we could expect the release
in 2021 next May the 9th Fast & Furious
film is to be released in the cinemas
not much is known about the plot yet but
there were already some reports about
the actress recently it was announced
that John Cena will be part of the cast
according to the magazine deadline there
are now three more new members to
announce
among them are Finn Kol known from peaky
blinders Winnie Bennett and NS a why the
latter true had supporting worlds in
Ninja Assassin and ghost in the shell'
the three actors who are still
relatively unknown are not really a big
surprise however at least something is
happening behind the scenes in Fast and
Furious 9 it's been known for some time
that besides Wendy's with Michelle
Rodriguez Tyrese Gibson and Ludacris
will be part of the new movie the
director will be Justin Lin Fast and
Furious 9 will probably be on screen on
22nd of May 2020 last week Netflix
published first pictures of the upcoming
the rich were serious
it shows an yaqula torres yennefer and
Freya allen as Gerald's daughter ciri
the witcher geralt himself is occupied
by henry cavill and looks remarkably
similar to Jarrell from the video games
an official started for the Netflix
series is not known yet but according to
an insider source it will be December
20th 2019 more details will be available
from July 19th on because then the San
Diego comic-con will surely reveal more
details there are news from behind the
scenes of 125 rami malek has revealed in
an interview with the mirror that the
bond will and he personifies will not be
a classic terrorist who spreads disaster
for religious or ideological reasons
this was his condition in a telephone
conversation with director Cary Fukunaga
the news are joined by information from
male online
according to which the bond villain uses
genetic engineering which would move the
Bond franchise a bit further in the
direction of science fiction
another thing that costs a lot of
tension on the set was the sudden
departure of Bond veteran Grace Jones
who was supposed to play a role in bond
25 but when she found out that she was
only supposed to have a small cameo
appearance she left the set in a rage
and ended her work on bond 25 whether
the plan started on April 3rd 2020 can
still be kept will surely depend on
whether more scandals around the
shooting of 125 will happen in the
future
and usually a new movie has been running
in the USA since Tuesday instead of
Friday as usual and this movie is
spider-man far from home and it is
looking like the Marva blockbuster will
break some records already on the first
day of the US release the film earned a
fabulous thirty nine point two million
u.s. dollars which marks a new North
American record because never a Tuesday
release has ever earned so much money
before spider-man far from home is thus
outperforming its predecessor the
amazing spider-man from 2012 with a
difference of about four million u.s.
dollars it is estimated that the one
hundred and twenty five million dollar
mark will be correct in the US by Sunday
and there are even some estimates that
spider-man far from home will be the
first film in the series to correct the
billion dollar mark
[Music]